(drumming)
- I'm on board with this.
- I need to get this into this.
- Is this poncho part of it?
- God damn it.
(buzzer)
- Oh, can I not even do that.
- So I need to put that into that?
God damn it.
- Don't think I can
grip that with my teeth,
so I'm gonna go the toe route.
- I mean that just leaves my mouth, right?
- I feel like I'm going to hurt myself.
(cup rattling)
(blowing)
- Nope, that didn't work.
- Easy.
(moans)
- Uh unh, uh, unh.
- This doesn't make any sense.
(blowing)
(laughing)
- Oh, okay.
- Get it, get it, just go for it.
(clunking)
Go for it kid.
Touch down.
(slurping)
(spitting)
(blowing)
(coughing)
- That coffee is in the cup.
Let's get some creamer.
Boom.
And sugar.
Don't need it.
(cups clinking)
(slurping)
A little cold.